[Music]
there's certain things were very
confident in that we really believe are
true about the universe from the
scientific perspective that should bear
upon however it is you want to set up
your own view of the meaning of life and
where it all came from so let's get
there and I want to start with the very
beginning if it were 2500 years ago if
we were the ancient Greeks thinking
about how stuff worked in the universe
the very first physics questions right
think about what Aristotle says about
how things move he says that if
something is going to move you have to
push it if there is motion it's because
there is a mover there's a natural state
of things which is basically to sit
where they want to be and then not move
anymore
and guess what Aristotle is correct if
what you want to do is describe the
world of your immediate senses if you
want this to move you have to push it if
I stop pushing it it will stop moving
once again right he's not crazy
the car is not going to move unless
someone is pushing it even if there's a
very adorable little puppy dog pushing
the car driving the car you need some
fuel inside to get it to go okay it took
hundreds of years a lot of deep thought
to realize that as true as this is for
our everyday lives it's not how the
world works at a fundamental level and
by fundamental in this sense we mean
what are the rules so that we can start
with them and figure everything else out
rather than starting right at what we
immediately see so what Aristotle says
subscribe
successfully describes when we
immediately see but we can't go deeper
with it it was over a thousand years
later that persian physicist actually he
was not a physicist he was a doctor
medical doctor named even Sina he was a
medical doctor but in his spare time he
came up with new laws of physics so he
invented something that we now call
conservation of momentum even seeing it
was the first to point out that if you
were moving but you were moving in
vacuum in empty space then what would
happen is you would continue to move
forever at the same velocity the fact
that when you push something
it moves and then stops that's not a
fundamental law of nature that's just
because there's friction in the room
right there's air resistance there's the
force being acted upon you by the ground
and so forth these days we build
spacecraft that are literally out there
in empty space and indeed they will move
in a straight line more or less the same
speed forever and ever or until
something else bumps into them now this
seems like a really good way to start
torturing our undergraduate physics
students with puzzles about inclined
planes and pendulums and things like
that but it's more than that this is a
very profound deep shift in how we think
about the nature of the world in the
Aristotelian world what we thought about
at the most fundamental level was a
world of purposes and goals right there
was a reason why something was doing
something in a different way so
Aristotle took this to its logical
conclusion the world moves therefore
there must be a mover for the world a
mover that was not itself moved an
unmoved mover which you could identify
with God if he wanted to this point of
view which was then reified in classical
mechanics with Isaac Newton and so forth
says something different it says that
the motion of the world is natural does
not require an outside mover it just is
what the world wants to do and as I
mentioned Isaac Newton developed this
into a whole theory of mechanics
classical mechanics right that's what we
really torture our little students with
when we say you know two balls are
hitting each other you tell me given
where the balls are at the beginning
they're coming in at a certain position
with a certain velocity you tell me how
they will scatter off of each other
it wasn't even Newton it wasn't till
quite a long while afterward the
pierre-simon Laplace realized that there
was an enormous ly important implication
of Newtonian physics of classical
mechanics what we torture our students
with is the question given that you
start with two balls coming in at a
certain angle certain position you tell
me they were where they will go in the
future
well the Laplace says is if I believe
these equations you tell me I could just
as easily tell you what the ball
we're doing at the end of the experiment
and ask you where they had come from
there is something called conservation
of information not only is there
conservation of momentum which is pretty
straightforward there's something even
deeper about the fundamental nature of
reality that the amount of information
you need to specify what the world is
doing is the same at any one moment of
time and that information in principle
specifies the entire past and future of
the universe
so the plos invented what we call
Laplace's daemon Laplace didn't call it
that he was an atheist he called that a
vast intelligence he said imagine
there's a vast intelligence that knew
the position and velocity of everything
in the universe had infinite computing
power and knew all the laws of physics
- that vast intelligence the future in
the past would be as known and as clear
as the present moment is so what this
does is once and for all removes the
vocabulary of causes and purposes and
goals from the fundamental laws of
physics the fundamental laws of physics
in this view are ones of patterns if
this is happening at one moment here's
what will happen if the next moment
here's what was happening at the last
moment why is it that way that's not a
question you're supposed to ask right
that's not part of the fundamental laws
of physics that's just what they are now
of course this paradigm set up by Isaac
Newton we know better than Isaac Newton
now right we have quantum mechanics we
have relativity and so forth but it's
the same basic kind of idea these days
we have what is called the standard
model of particle physics here's the
standard model of particle physics in
one short slide this is the cartoon that
you may have seen of an atom okay so
there's a nucleus with protons and
neutrons around the protons and neutrons
there are electrons and the electrons
are held to the nucleus by
electromagnetism inside the protons and
neutrons there are quarks that are held
together with gluons and the spillover
from that gluon force holds the protons
and neutrons together occasionally
there's something called the weak
nuclear force that turns a proton into a
neutron or vice-versa and spits out a
neutrino
the whole thing has the property that
everything is pulled to everything else
by the force of gravity and meanwhile
everything has a background which we
call the higgs field that was the last
piece of this puzzle we discovered the
vibrations of the higgs field that we
called the Higgs boson just in 2012
okay so 2012 put the finishing touches
on this picture that we now call the
standard model of particle physics now
what I want to claim you don't have to
believe me right I mean I'm going to say
things that I think are true and
honestly you should believe me but you
don't have to there's no normative force
that you have to but you should
understand what I'm saying what I'm
saying is there's plenty that we don't
know about the laws of physics but
there's something that we do know there
is a regime an area of possible
applications where we do understand the
laws of physics and that regime that the
domain of validity for the laws as we
currently understand them includes
everything going on in this tent
everything going on in this tent and for
that matter everything you've ever seen
with your eyes heard with your ears
touch with your fingers in your life we
understand the laws of physics that
govern what those things are this is
what we call the core theory in physics
it's the standard model of particle
physics plus Einstein's general
relativity you may have heard that
gravity which general relativity
describes does not play well with
quantum mechanics we don't have a
quantum theory of gravity and that's
true but we have a pretty good quantum
theory of gravity well we don't have is
the final quantum theory of gravity
we can't explain the Big Bang or black
holes but if you want to explain why
raindrops fall down rather than up you
can explain that in both quantum and
gravitational terms right now so
everything that you've ever seen or
touched we have a theory that explains
that of course we don't understand dark
matter dark energy the origin of the
universe and we certainly don't
understand how these individual bits and
pieces come together to make things like
chemicals or aardvarks or financial
systems and so forth
okay calm
phenomena that are beyond the laws of
fundamental physics we certainly had a
lot to do in understanding them but
whatever that work will eventually be it
better be compatible with the
fundamental laws of physics I don't
understand how the human brain works in
any great detail but I know the brain is
made of atoms so if I'm gonna come up
with a theory of how the brain works it
better be compatible with the known laws
of physics now I know what I know what
you're thinking I would only believe it
if they showed me the underlying
equations you've come to the right place
here you go the good news is it's only
one equation okay in Isaac Newton's time
it was F equals MA Newton's second law
forces mass times acceleration if you
were Laplace is demon in a classical
world so someone gave you the billiard
balls the laws of physics you would have
in your brain where Newton's laws and
you would know how the billiard balls
bumped into each other if you are a
modern quantum mechanical Laplace is a
demon using the core theory to do your
predictions this is the equation you
would use for more debates talks and
interviews subscribe today to the
institute of arts and ideas at iai TV
you